so as a warning you give this to your
date you might get married
but you know hey guys my name is tayo
and if you're single like me we all know
dayton has been a bit of a challenge
during this time
why because restaurants are closed we
physically can't be near each other
and there's a lot of safety protocols
that's in place so when my friends at
tastia asked me what would be my ideal
date night i had to get a tad bit
creative with this one so today i'm
going to show you how to make my
ultimate home-cooked tropical date night
recipes whether you're cooking with
somebody
in person or if you're cooking with
somebody virtually we're gonna begin by
making a fried plantain salad so i love
to travel you know the caribbean islands
is one of my favorite places to visit
and a lot of the recipes and the dishes
and the flavors that really connect back
to my nigerian roots
i want somebody to be able to connect
back to my upbringing
taste the flavors of you know who i am
and also you want to make a good first
impression
so first step let's go ahead and slice
up this plantain the reason why i
love plantains is because growing up in
nigeria
we grew up on plantains it's like one of
my favorite
to this day the thing about plantains is
you always
want to go with the ones that are like
ripe nicely
those plantains have the best flavor all
right so we're going to go ahead and get
this oil
nice and hot before we put our plantains
on
so the temperature you want to have this
baby at is medium high
so while i'm waiting for my oil to heat
up let's talk about virtual dating so
i've been on a virtual date before
it's fun and it's also a great way to
stay connected with somebody so i
encourage you guys to give it a try as
well too there's nothing wrong with a
little bit of snapchat
the oil is ready to go so let's go ahead
and put the plantains in for two to
three minutes on both sides
until it's nice and golden so cooking
together
whether you're in person or virtual it's
a great icebreaker
it's also a great way for you guys to be
able to bond and
spend time together so let's go ahead
and get these baby turned over
as you can see here this color texture
is exactly what you want if my date
doesn't like plantains
we can't date honestly so our plantains
are ready so we're just going to go
ahead and get this
onto a paper towel this is a love
language right here ladies and gentlemen
so if you really want to make somebody
happy
you want to make them smile your
plantains have to look like this
so i'm going to go ahead and fry my
onions and pepper for
three to four minutes until it's soft
and after that go ahead and make the
dressing we're going to start off by
adding
apple cider vinegar add in some honey
some dijon mustard
some salt gently whisk this all together
gently want to add in some oil you
really don't want to dump the whole oil
in here it's like being on the first
date you want to take it nice and slow
you don't want to go in
too fast so the dressing is complete now
let's bring it all together
plate it with some arugula add in your
peppers
and onions and then your plantains and
you can plate this whatever way you feel
this is where you can show off your
creativity
take some avocados take some green
onions add a little bit of pistachio for
some crunch then you're going to add in
some cilantro
and last but not least your dressing
here is my fried plantain salad promise
you when you date taste this
it's going to put a big smile on your
face and it's a great way to kick off
the evening together so if you think
this looks good
wait till you see what the entree is the
main dish the dish that's going to win
them over coconut curry shrimp back home
in nigeria we cook with a lot of flavor
and a lot of taste
and this dish speaks to that exactly
we're going back to the islands
so we're going to start things off with
a butter so you want your butter to melt
completely over medium heat once
that is done we're gonna add in our
onions
so i love onions so we're just gonna let
this cook until it's nice and soft
my advice for somebody that's going on a
first date is
just be yourself have fun just live in a
moment
so onions are nice and soft now let's
add in
another buzzer in there gently stir this
together
so i'm going to go ahead and add in my
green and red peppers
and cook this for three to four minutes
until
it's soft cooking is a great time for
you to get to know somebody
you know sometimes you laugh when things
go right sometimes you laugh when things
go wrong
so if you're not a good cook it's
totally fine cooking is a team activity
it's a great time for you to bond
together and get to know each other
so our pepper and onions are ready
now let's build the main core of this
dish so i'm adding in
unsweetened coconut milk some fish sauce
some
lemon juice black pepper some salt some
sugar
we cooked this back in nigeria and one
of my favorite recipes and dish
some jell-o fries maybe going to add
some curry in this
this baby right here some chicken born
yarn but in nigeria we call this
maggi um we literally cooked this with
everything
now we're just gonna stir it all up
together and you see the thing about
cooking too
is have fun with it if you ever had like
good food like great delicious food
it's made by someone that's just
genuinely just happy
i remember going to uh columbia went out
for breakfast one morning
i heard like this lady singing at the
back i don't know somebody's mom's my
auntie's my
grandma and when the dish came out when
i said that
had to be one of the best meals i've
ever had i was like girl i love you
and as you can see here our curry
coconut sauce
is coming together nicely so i'm gonna
bring the sauce to a boil
and then we're just gonna reduce the
heat and let this simmer for
10 minutes so while we wait for our
sauce to be complete on the first day
things might get awkward but it's okay
don't panic it happens it's a great time
for you to ask personal questions to get
to know the person oh
sauce is ready smells delicious
so now we're just gonna add in the
shrimp so the shrimps in the sauce we're
just gonna let this cook for
three to four minutes until it's pink
and ready to go
it's like when you're on your first date
you want to look nice you want to
present yourself
nicely so i'm going to show you a trick
on how to elevate this dish
so your food looks just as good as you
do
you want a nice little small bowl right
so you take your brown rice put your
brown rice in a bowl if you don't have a
small bowl at home you can use a small
cup and what you
do is you press down on it nice and firm
so what you do is you take your plate
here's the magic flip slowly
nah i don't like it let's do that over
slowly
boom and now let's add in the curry
coconut shrimp
you want to add in the sauce pour it
around the edges real quick
this is looking delicious so i'm gonna
garnish this with some fresh cilantros
add in some pop of color and to complete
this dish
this is this is it this dish right here
this is the winning dish this is gonna
win your date over
all right we're not done yet so what's a
good meal without a good drink
so our choice of drink tonight is a
mango guava ombre cocktail so this
cocktail is easy to make it's refreshing
so we're just gonna go ahead and add in
our mangoes into the blender add in some
water
so all we're doing right now is just
making a puree
boom you're going to throw some ice in
your cup
so i'm adding in my guava nectar splash
of lime
slowly pour in your grenadine now you're
gonna spoon in
your mango puree
two cherries of top and some mint
there you go ladies and gentlemen your
super simple mango guava ombre mocktail
so this is great but if you want to take
it to that next level add in your choice
of liquor
for me i'm gonna go over the shot of
tequila now it's time to bring it all
together
so ladies and gentlemen here's the final
spread we have here our fried plantain
salad curry coconut
shrimp served with brown rice and the
mango guava ombre mocktail so these
recipes are short enough to impress your
date in person and they're super easy to
make if you're far apart on a virtual
date so we're just going to do a little
taste test
eeny meeny curry coconut shrimp here
[Music]
see when you're speechless this was
delicious so as a warning if you give
this to your
date you might get married but you know
make sure you send me an invite too
all right guys let me know what you
think by leaving a comment below make
sure you follow me on instagram
at tayo's creation and until next time
peace by the way we're on a date right
now so what are you thinking about let
you tried this mocktail yet
amazing
you